in this lesson we're going to talk about
the important concept of polynomials
factors zeros remainders so let's get
right into this lesson and I'll show you
some of the key concepts so first of all
a polynomial is like a smooth curve like
so and this polynomial we're calling f
of X and the key thing that you want to
know for the SATA important concept
understand is what are the zeros so
first of all the zeros another name for
the zeros are just two x-intercepts so
the reason they call them zeros is
because at this point where it crosses
the x axis the y coordinate is zero so
you want to make sure that you kind of
realize these are like synonyms the
x-intercepts the zeros the root the
solutions these all mean the same thing
but if you know what the zero is like
meaning you know where it crosses the
x-axis then you automatically know what
the factor is so what is the factor well
factor is always going to be X minus the
zero okay so the idea is if you were to
set this equal to 0 X plus 3 equal to
zero you would get negative 3 so that's
the idea x minus r0 is a factor and if
you set that factor equal to 0 you get
that x intercept or that route or that
solution now here you can see it's also
crossing at two it's also crossing the
x-axis at six so if we wanted to factor
this you can see the factors are going
to be X plus 3 that's x minus negative 3
the two natives cancel X minus positive
2 and X minus positive 6 so when you
look at these factors you said 20 you're
actually getting the opposite sign
they're getting positive 6 positive to
negative 3 right okay another way to
write this is in the function notation
so f of negative 3 equals 0 meaning if
you put negative 3 into this function
looking into the equation which is not
listed here by the way you get the
y-intercept with a y-value which is zero
so that tells you that negative 3 is an
x-intercept okay so if you put negative
3 in you get zero out that's the Y value
which means is crossing the x axis at
negative 3 okay so what that also means
is that you know X plus 3 is a factor
and if you were to divide the polynomial
the function by X plus 3 it would go in
evenly with no remainder
okay now if we look over here if you
divide the function f of X by X minus 7
here the remainder is going to be 1
because you can see if you go over 27
the X minus 7 is like our factor if you
go over 27 that's like our x-coordinate
the y-coordinate is not 0 it's one
because if X minus 7 was a factor then
when you put seven into the equation you
would get zero for your remainder in
this case you're getting a remainder one
that's our y-coordinate so we want to
understand this concept to review this
concept of the zeros the x-intercepts
the factors which are X minus the zeros
or the x-intercepts and then the idea of
the remainder now if there's no
remainder then it means it's a zero you
know 6 is 0 and if you were to put a
divide the polynomial by X minus 6 it
would go easily with no remainder if
there is a remainder it means at that
point is not on the x axis and that
remainder is just going to be the y
coordinate of the polynomial so let's
get into some examples and now pause the
video so you can do these on your own
like normal just to get some more
practice and experience so example once
is given the table for the function G of
X at this table here which must be a
factor of G of X ok so pause the video
what do you think seeking do this on
your own is it x + 1 X minus 5x minus 2
or X plus 3 well one thing you'll notice
is that so if you put negative 1 you get
two out what that means is we were
graphing this when X is negative 1 the Y
value would be too ok so that's not it
ok x is 0 Y is 5 that's the y intercept
but we're looking for the x-intercepts
1620 oh here we go so when X is to the y
coordinate is 0 that's our x intercept
which means that X minus 2 is a factor
so the best dancer here is letter C so
don't get distracted by you know this
solution at this point here we're
actually looking for where the y
coordinate is 0 that's going to be the x
intercept and then X minus the x
intercept that's a factor ok so that's
the key for example one now example 2 it
says how many zeroes right does the
polynomial have so here's our polynomial
here it's wondering how many zeroes does
it have so go ahead and pause the video
think about this one is at one two three
or four
well in this example you can see it's
crossing the x-axis here here here and
here so that means that it's going to
have one two three four zeros the reason
again is they call these zeros is
because the y-coordinate at these points
is zero so I have 40 so the best answer
is going to be letter D so again review
this concept of zeros factors X
intercepts remainders and these examples
here if you need to and I'll see in the
next lesson